before we begin Dead Space has a lot of
flashing lights or strobe effects that
may be uncomfortable for some people so
figure discretion is advised
Dead Space is one of the most well-known
survival horror games of all time it's
not the most populars that would
probably go to the game that actually
popularized the genre but Dead Space
scratches an itch that no other survival
horror game has ever been able to do for
me it's a beautifully woven strand of
sci-fi and horror that ends up creating
an unforgettable experience the core
idea of its gameplay is unique and its
story is equal parts captivating and
horrifying today I want to spend some
time talking about this series and not
only explain to you what Dead space's
story is about but also how its external
systems create a feeling of dread in the
player how its progression and the story
feels natural and fluid how the gameplay
complements the story and how our man
Isaac is about to go on the Journey of a
lifetime let's get started Dead Space 1
starts with a video a video of a woman
talking it's a message addressed to her
boyfriend and our protagonist Isaac
Clark we've learned from the
conversation that follows that Isaac's
girlfriend Nicole works on the ship
they're visiting called the USG ishimura
Isaac is on a maintenance ship called
the USG kelian apparently ishimura's
Communications blacked out so This
five-man Crew is sent here to determine
the cause onboard the ship is Kendra and
Hammond don't worry about the pilots
they'll be Irrelevant in just a few
minutes due to some malfunctions the
ship crashed into the ishimura but the
crew managed to survive the team makes
it to the front door but they're stuck
so they have Isaac fix the door and it's
here where we get our first encounter
the ishimura seems to be inhabited by
these alien life forms another crew is
going to need to escape if they want to
survive as fast as the game wants the
player to get into combat is as fast as
this video is going to need to go into a
long ramble about the world of Dead
Space because without it nothing going
forward will make much sense much of
this information is either in the
current games database or in future
games but Humanity within Dead Space has
managed to achieve space travel and
inhabit other planets like Mars and
Saturn while this may sound good most of
humanity is struggling the world of
Earth seems to be overpopulated and
under resourced as non-renewable
resources have all been spent so
Humanity took to the stars in order to
find more planets to live on not only to
make earth less cramped but also to mine
those planets so it can give Earth its
extra resources however after some time
even those new colonies ran out lots of
Hope in the species survival was lost
until the creation of Planet cracking
using some advanced technology it's
possible to dig deep into the planet's
inner layers and harvest the minerals
Inside Planet cracking sounds like a
cool term for advanced mining Until you
realize that it's literal The Rock
underneath the ushumura is part of the
planet the ishimura is a flagship Planet
cracker designed to specifically take
massive chunks out of a planet then melt
down any materials from that chunk due
to how expensive and time-consuming the
process is the planet is first mapped up
by experts to determine if cracking it
open is worth the hassle once that's
complete the next step is to set up a
base on the planets that the planet
cracker can use its tethers to pull it
apart this process however is very
delicate and needs to be watched over at
all times the point of Planet cracking
is do not just take a hole out and leave
but to dismantle the game entire planet
one piece at a time according to various
reports in game this method of resource
Gathering is very efficient it's
impossible though to fit the entire
piece on the ship at one time so they
break it up into larger balls one report
stated that their first haul was a
10-ton ball that had 6.5 tons of
minerals inside this means that this
planet is Rich with resources and the
ishimura is going to come back with a
good haul but as I said the whole
process is very delicate as it can cause
some serious issues for anyone on or
near the planet as it has the potential
to disrupt the gravitational pull that
holds the planets in place that's why
many of these planets are carefully
selected and are likely far away from
the solar system that Humanity inhabits
the ishimura is here to do another
routine Planet cracking but is not the
only reason it's here but we'll have to
get to that later as stated Isaac and
Company are here to investigate the ship
since its Communications went dark but I
think we can already tell how that
happened these alien creatures are
called Necromorphs not much is known
about them now and won't be for some
time but to give you a brief idea what
they are Necromorphs are repurposed
humans these spikes with their hands
would be seem to be the person's bones
and one of the creatures uses their 10
hendrils to keep itself attached to the
wall which looks like its intestines
then Necromorphs are also related to an
object called the marker but once again
more on that later I've played a lot of
sci-fi games where Humanity runs into
the same issues like a lack of resources
but cracking open whole planets to mine
for these resources is definitely a new
one and I gotta say I'm pretty fond of
the idea it's Unique and very much in
the realm of Science Fiction the early
chapters of Dead Space don't explain too
much of this mostly because there are
more important things at stake like
trying to survive but this also ends up
halting a lot of the game's pacing Dead
Space follows the same style other
trilogies have like a mass effect but
the first game is made to set the tone
of the world and introduce all its Rich
lore before giving the player the real
story closer to the end as such Dead
Space 1 only really starts getting good
with its main story around chapter 10
and this is a 12 chapter game everything
before that is just about escaping the
ship well actually the whole plot is
trying to escape the ship but many of
the details that would be expanded upon
in further entries are shown towards the
end personally this has never bothered
me mostly because Dead Space has
multiple entries so if one title
especially the first game doesn't expand
on some broader scope of the game world
I won't complain plus gameplay is just
as important as if that's not
interesting enough no one's going to
make it to the end anyway and speaking
of that gameplay we can see that it
follows the standard mechanics of
survival horror limited ammo scary
monsters Inventory management and all
those other important parts that create
the genre if you played Resident Evil
then this style will be incredibly
familiar in fact even the presentation
and systems are the same in the sense
that each game is made to be enjoyed
multiple times as inventory carries over
to the next playthrough and combat
starts almost immediately as to not slow
down the pace of repeat playthroughs and
it also has backtracking involved not
just in level but across chapters as
you'll be constantly moving through each
part of the level quite a few times and
then possibly revisit that same exact
area later in the game when you're
stronger the only difference is are that
Isaac can actually walk and shoot at the
same time and combat is more about
placement rather than accuracy the head
is the go-to spot to shoot when it comes
to shooter games but Dead Space forces
the player to forget those habits
shooting specific limbs is critical to
surviving the ishimura the first enemy
you face is a standard Necromorph with a
wide enough distance between each limb
to make aiming a bit easier shooting the
leg will cause them to fall over and
shooting the arm right after more often
than not deliver the killing blow its
unique style of combat and one that ends
up making the Gunplay a lot harder as
you can't just simply default to the
head when faced with a group the only
issue though is how to balance all this
a week or two ago depending on when this
video goes live I covered a game called
soma both of these games are horror
games but Soma has no defensive option
so it's all about hiding and Running
Dead Space gives the player Power by
allowing them to upgrade Isaac's health
and armor and also allow them to buy new
weapons becoming stronger is
antithetical to the horror genre but
Dead Space doesn't follow the standard
Trope it's all about having a delicate
balance of power and horror so that
neither side goes too far as this could
end up damaging the experience of the
game too much power in the game feels
scary as a result it also makes combat
easier because you have extra ammunition
to spare part of the balance of gameplay
and horror is knowing that you're one
step away from burning a large hole in
your inventory that used to house dozens
of rounds of ammo and a handful of
health kits on the opposite end though
too little power in the game becomes
difficult this every now and then is not
a problem but constantly restarting will
cause the player to view the arena less
like a room and more like a puzzle and
once the player is analyzing the spawn
rates and knows what enemies are aware
you've lost them for the remainder of
the time in that room this however is
more player dependent but the devs
behind the levels do actually place the
enemies in those rooms so it is on them
as well something less player dependent
though is the horror horror is not hard
to create it's hard to maintain though
add a few jump scares and loud sound
effects and call it a day but can you
keep that up for the remainder of the
game of course not if so anyone could do
it it requires not only precise timing
between scares but also originality
among those scares I never felt like I
had the upper hand at any point but
conversely none of the enemies did
either sometimes I had more ammo that I
could shoot other times I was scraping
the bottom of the barrel for the last
round but this never caused an imbalance
once this is due to how diverse the
encounters are throughout the game their
various forms of Necromorphs in Dead
Space all of which have specific weak
spots you can Target like the legs or
tendrils if it has any even all the way
up to chapter 9 the game was still
throwing in new enemies as it introduced
this incredibly fast type of Necromorph
sometimes you'll even run into the same
type of enemy but a different color
which in this case means it has more
Health this change in enemy design is
also complemented by the levels and
environment that these fights take place
in it wasn't hard to pinpoint when
combat was going to start it was hard
though to correctly guess what I was
going to be facing like in the first
lockdown event the player has it's
simple you can't leave until all the
enemies are defeated but then the game
keeps the lockdown idea and puts it in a
similar room and adds different enemies
then widens the space and adds even more
types of enemies or just locks the
player in one room this change also
transfers over to the encounters that
don't force the player to stay in one
place some encounters are in a large
room or in a hallway you'll never know
when combat could start Dead Space also
wants the player to really be present in
the world as much as possible and not be
clogged down by various gameplay systems
which is why the HUD is practically
non-existent all that's included is the
health bar on the spine the stasis bar
on the right and the current magazine on
the gun and that's it going this route
removes all those flashy icons in
claustrophobic UI that some games have
allowing you to be enveloped in the
world and its horror and it's this HUD
couple with the seamless blend of power
and horror that makes Dead Space a
perfect survival horror game but just as
the game goes from Silent to scary very
quickly so too has this video gone from
informational to ironic as I've just
spent the past few minutes talking about
Resident people and dead space's
gameplay in a video that claims to be
about the story of dead space and there
are two reasons for that firstly it's
because without Resident Evil this game
wouldn't exist and not just in the sense
that Resident Evil was what popularized
survival Horror in the first place but
because the devs literally pivoted their
entire production when Resident Evil 4
was released Dead Space was originally
going to be something more into System
Shock and in a way some of its influence
is still present but when Resident Evil
4 was released with its new camera
perspective and plot the team knew that
they wanted to make something like that
instead it's not often a studio already
missed a copying another game usually
game journalists handle that job yet the
horror genre doesn't really seem to
carry the same negative effects that
other genres might suffer because of
this a few months from now a game I plan
to talk about at some point called
Callisto protocol is releasing which
looks exactly like dead space now it is
made by the same director but still had
you shown this to me without the title I
would have thought this was dead space
4. it's even got the same minimalist HUD
that shows the health on the back and
ammo on the gun and yet despite some
minor backlash for the influence most of
what I've seen is positive many people
including myself are very excited for
this game though whether or not Calista
protocol ends up actually being good as
a conversation will have at a later date
regardless despite it being similar to
dead space in more ways than one The
Gaming Community doesn't really seem to
care and if anything is happy with the
comparison because it's more dead space
the second reason is that sometimes the
gameplay can match the tone of the story
it's hard to pull this off sometimes
since gameplay can be very divorced from
the story but in dead space's case this
works deadspace's story is all about
exploring an unknown location filled
with terrifying and creepy enemies the
tone of the game is fear and this fear
is shown in the gameplay running out of
ammo causes fear and just walking around
the level can create fear in the player
you feel like you yourself are on the
ishimura not just controlling someone
who is and this further heightens the
gameplay experience most of this is down
to the sound design and temperament on
the devs did not throw out as much
horror as possible but most of this is
also on the visual Fidelity of its
environment Dead Space is a 14 year old
game and yet it still looks great some
of the faces could use a bit of a
touch-up but other than that the game is
Stellar both inside and outside the ship
their Israeli a time you'll be
disappointed with its visuals and
hearing that there's not going to be a
dead space remake coming it's only going
to make the game better even if it is
ironic that EA is creating the their own
Necromorph by Reviving a game series
they killed made by a studio they shut
down returning back to the story Isaac
now has to figure out what to do next
thankfully his crewmates will task him
with doing things like repairing parts
of the ship or turning on specific Power
Systems and the best part is Isaac can't
argue with them because he can't talk
even though this would change in later
titles Isaac for now is a silent
protagonist a Felix Island protagonists
are more suited towards RPGs with a
character is a blank slate but this
works tremendously well in this entry as
the silence adds to the atmosphere
you'll never hear Isaac's thoughts on
anything which means the player can be
swayed by what Isaac is thinking which
will be relevant later and just walk
into the ishimura in complete silence is
terrifying if Isaac were to speak at all
during this it would remove some of the
tension this silence makes every other
noise have meaning even if it's just
something as small as a floor creaking
as it could mean a Necromorph is nearby
it also makes the few times you can hear
Isaac also have more meaning Isaac's
only voice lines are Grunts and screams
which pairs well with the gore of this
game it's quite obvious from the footage
that this game can be quite gross at
times enemies and people can be
dismembered and disemboweled at any
point so should particular enemy bother
you enough you can take out your anger
by slamming your foot into its chest
cavity but this score wasn't just
created for the Player's enjoyment if
anything its inclusion could provoke the
opposite effect Isaac isn't safe from a
gruesome fate either in fact I would
argue it's more of an oddity if Isaac
doesn't lose a limb at some point during
his death animation Dead Space is one of
a handful of games where getting the
character killed actually makes you more
upset than angry most games dying just
means you have to reset to your last
save or checkpoint and go again their
deaths may be quite tame as well like
fainting or falling over Dead Space
keeps the score consistent by allowing
Isaac to be dismembered right in front
of your eyes this emotion of sadness is
also heightened due to Isaac's silence
as his deaths are the only time you can
actually hear some form of expression he
will scream constantly while dying and
similar to how the noises aboard the
ship stand out so too does this
[Music]
foreign
it makes you feel terrible even though
Isaac is just a character in a game
because the player feels responsible for
condemning him to such a fate it ends up
becoming a wake-up call because now it's
not just about leaving the ishimura
because you want Isaac to survive but
because you don't want Isaac to die once
Isaac escapes the initial attack he
comes across the plasma cutter an iconic
weapon in the series due to its unique
firing mode and wonderful sound design
the plasma cutter plays into the game's
style of combat by allowing you to
switch between a horizontal and vertical
angle so you can always hit a limb no
matter the creature other weapons focus
on other forms of damage like the
assault rifle which is about his bog
standards you can get or the line gun
which is only horizontal but as a wider
spread but the plasma cutter is the Old
Reliable you can never go wrong with it
the greatest part about the weapon is
that despite its design it's not
actually a gun it's a tool used in
mining operations for cutting soft
material and Flash is about as soft as
you can get quite a few of the weapons
were designed like this as well the line
gun contact beam and disc gripper looked
like they were designed for mining
operations the only actual gun in this
game seems to be the pulse rifle it's a
nice change from a genre that focuses on
various types of standard Weaponry but
it also fits into the lore in two
distinct ways the ishimura is a planet
cracker so mining equipment and its
relative ammo should be quite plentiful
and Isaac is also an engineer who has
likely used these items before so while
he may not have actual combat experience
he is very handy with the tools he uses
inside combat it's the unique details
like these that made Dead Space Stand
Out amongst not just horror games but
games in general as there really is
nothing like it Isaac's first objective
is to now fix the tram station this will
allow him and the others to get around
the ishimura without getting attacked
but once that's fixed things start to
become a bit tedious Dead Space is split
into 12 chapters and it isn't until the
last third of the game that the story
actually starts in a way though this
does fit with the current predicament as
the story is partially about escaping
the ship but what's more important in
regards to the story is the source of
these hallucinations over the course of
the game Kendra will bring up how her
brother keeps showing up next to her and
Isaac will also get constant messages
from Nicole these hallucinations are
tied to the real reason behind the
ship's infestation in the world of Dead
Space exists a church called The Church
of unitology it's a more perverted
version of Scientology even if that is a
pretty Twisted group already but just
like Scientology unitology believes that
humans are more than just flesh claiming
that life does not end here on Earth but
continues for Untold eons and spirit
form the two also have the same pyramid
scheme structure where members pay their
way to higher positions than the church
in fact this is why Isaac distrusts them
so much because his own mother used his
college tuition to pay for a higher
position in the church which meant that
Isaac had to go to a less prestigious
school for his engineering degree where
the two differ though is in their
believability Scientology to just about
everyone is a cult and unitology is the
same but the current world circumstances
make their ideas more compelling the
average person in Dead Space isn't worth
their weight in gold everyone is
Expendable because if they die that
means it's your mouths to feed Planet
cracking is likely extremely dangerous
but people do it anyway because they
need a paycheck and once again if
someone dies oh well it's less money out
of the CEO's pocket unitologists believe
that after death they'll be reunited
with Humanity's Divine creators in a
world where no one is Happy believing in
a better life after their death is more
palatable than believing that their only
life will ever be one of and uncertainty
the church also uses various forms of
teaching like indoctrination to convince
some of its members to join and they
often perform mass suicide since the
whole point is to be reunited after
death unitology started though because
of an object called the marker this
current marker which from this point
forward will be called the red marker
was found on the planet ages 7 the one
that ishimura was cracking open before
the events of the game a group of
researchers found what they called the
black marker on Earth the person who
found it was a man named Michael Altman
he became a martyr for the Church of
unitology as Altman believed this was
the first sign of alien life but he was
assassinated for this discovery so many
humanitologists believe it was the
government trying to cover up something
a lot of this story is twisted and
confusing because what actually happened
versus what unitology believes what
happened are different but I'll talk
about more of this in Dead Space 2 where
it's elaborated on when the government
found the black marker though they tried
to replicate the codes inscribed on it
and after some time they succeeded in
doing so this allowed them to create the
red marker the black marker is the real
marker the red marker is just a replica
with a different color using the red
marker they were able to study lots of
its effects but the team behind and the
research was instructed to keep it away
from Human colonies likely so people
couldn't figure out what they were doing
the creation of the red marker also
created a small microbial life form and
when one of the scientists forgot to
decontaminate they watched it latch onto
their dead skin cells and began to
self-replicate now this was likely
happening on the cellular level only
visible through a microscope but after
enough replication the life forms
started growing in size and in number
and this would eventually lead to a
Necromorph outbreak despite that though
the ishimura was still instructed to
crack open the planet and that's because
no one but the government knew this
experiment happened the planet of Ages 7
was restricted by Earth's current
government called earthka because of its
experiments that we just talked about
the CEC however who was the largest
Mining Company in the Galaxy went to
Asia 7 anyway because they discovered it
was rich with resources the Church of
unitology discovered that this planet
also had a red marker on it so they had
some other members Infiltrate The
ishimura as part of the crew Dr Mercer
Dr kein and Captain Matthias are members
of unitology they aren't the only
unitologist on the ship but just the
only ones of note once the outbreak was
discovered Captain Matthias decided to
shut down communication with the planet
and leave them to their fate as the
marker was the only goal Dr kind
realizing the true face of his religion
went against the captain and killed him
he'll also end up helping Isaac later in
chapter 11 as he believes that if they
return the marker back to the planet
then the infection will stop but what Dr
kind's beliefs had been broken due to
the infection Dr Mercer's was only
growing stronger he's quite fanatical
even by unitologist standards as he's
seen multiple times trapping Isaac in
rooms with this Necromorph that he
created and even stabbing other crew
members who likely didn't agree with the
teachings of unitology in a final act of
worship he let one of the Necromorphs
kill him said he could be reunited with
the marker's Creator as for a quick
summarization why these markers create
life forms how they were created and
pretty much anything surrounding the
marker is not expanded upon until
further titles but all you need to know
is that the red marker is the source of
these hallucinations the source of the
Necromorphs on the ishimura a religious
object for the Church of unitology and
that the red marker is specifically a
replica this plot about the marker also
inadvertently adds more depth to the
Dead Space 1 story as well as just
saying that it's about Isaac escaping
the ishimura isn't wrong but it's an
unfair generalization about the events
of the game as it's really about eyes
Isaac finding out what happened to
Nicole and also finding out the reason
behind the outbreak is a game of
multiple stories that all come together
under the same umbrella the story ends
up taking quite a sharp turn after this
as well trying to help Dr kind get the
marker back to the planet he's killed by
Kendra who takes the marker for herself
Kendra works for earthgupp and was sent
here to recover the marker and bring him
back to the government she clearly ends
up succeeding before Nicole of all
people comes by and attempts to thwart
her plans she's appeared in a few
hallucinations and even in person at one
point so her presence here isn't as
jarring as it seems but it is still
quite the shock regardless Nicole and
Isaac are able to call the ship back
which houses the marker foiling Kendra's
plans before they recalled the ship
though Kendra managed to use an escape
pod to land on the planet's surface and
Isaac and Nicole have to do the same if
they want to return the marker back to
the planet Nicole manages to guide Isaac
to where he needs to go before getting
betrayed again this Nicole was just a
hallucination made by the markers that
it could get Isaac to bring it back to
the hive mind the final boss of the game
before that happens though Kendra
arrives and tells Isaac to re-watch the
same video from the intro we see the
final few seconds which shows Nicole
killing herself she was dead the whole
time the reveal that she was dead is
really well done especially when you
consider that she was seen in person
twice so the idea that she was dead may
not have crossed her mind this game
however attempted to give you hints
about her true fate because in chapter 7
where you first meet her she just
appears out of nowhere and shows no
signs of fear towards the Necromorphs
that she's being attacked by and in
chapter 11 when recalling the shuttle
she says she's worried about the marker
because Kendra took it this is tied to
the reveal right after this the hive
mind seems to be behind the
hallucinations and is the one using
Isaac the hive mind is still using the
power of the marker but it wasn't the
marker doing it on its own as we thought
it's sort of a chain of command the hive
mind uses the marker to relay orders to
the other Necromorphs we can also assume
that it wanted the marker to return to
the surface because this whole plan was
Dr kind's idea but just like Isaac he
was seeing hallucinations of his wife
Emilia so the hive mind was controlling
him too the only question that remains
though is how is this stuff with Nicole
possible but I do believe there's an
answer for this since she's a
hallucination she can't open doors or
recall the shuttle like the game implies
she did so my theory is that the door
was already open but Isaac didn't notice
and that he was the one who recalled the
shuttle back at the end of chapter 11
but because the hallucination his mind
believed Nicole did it when it was
really him it's a stretch but it's the
only information we can really go off of
here according to Kendra's dialogue she
seems to imply that Isaac never finished
the video likely because he didn't want
to accept that she was dead so he never
watched it all the way through that's
why Isaac was convinced that Nicole was
real and ended up being tricked by her
the game was also trying to tell us from
the start that she was dead because the
first letter of each level spell out
Nicole is dead now you obviously
wouldn't have figured this out until
after the game but it was a nice Easter
egg regardless keeping in line with the
letters in the levels the last four
spelled dead and are also the only
levels with major character deaths
Hammond dies in chapter 9 Dr Mercer in
10 kind and 11 and now Kendra and 12. as
right when Isaac heads back to the
shuttle he meets with Kendra who is then
thrown into the wall and killed by the
hive mind this is the final boss of the
game and from a pure spectacle
standpoint it's a great looking fight
mechanically it's not too difficult the
glowing yellow weak spots are pretty
much a dead giveaway and as long as you
move side to side you pretty much won't
get hit my only issue though is when
you're picked up by the hive mind and
have to shoot its weak spot before Isaac
gets eaten the game doesn't let you zoom
in and aiming is only done by the
thumbstick and I don't know if it's just
me but these have always been such a
pain in the ass the same thing happens
in the two turret sections and the few
times you're being dragged across the
room and I hate doing these every time I
play the game it's hard enough as is to
keep the reticle steady but because the
camera isn't behind Isaac's back it
makes it even harder to aim in total
though they only take up like five
minutes Across The Seven Hour game so
obviously it's not enough to drag down
the experience but that doesn't mean
they aren't annoying after Isaac defeats
the hive mind he rushes to the shuttle
before that piece of Ages 7 we saw in
the intro crashes into the planet Isaac
newly Escapes in the chunk of rock
collides with the planet destroying the
marker and probably part of the planet
as well Isaac for the first time since
setting foot on the ishimura can now
finally relax now that the threat has
been dealt with he also removes his
helmet allowing us to see his face I
like this reveal because it feels
natural the man just went through hell
trying to escape so it's only fair he
lays down the guns and takes off his
helmet but he's not done yet as a
hallucination of Nicole scares him
before cuts to credits even without that
reveal though I think we all knew
Isaac's story wasn't over yet if
anything was on only just beginning
other than Necromorphs have made
themselves known Dead Space 1 like all
first games have the tough job of making
sure that not only is the game itself
good but it's also good enough to spawn
a sequel this means the game's
characters plots and world all need to
be addressed and worth the player's time
and the gameplay needs to be top-notch
as well despite how difficult of a task
this ends up becoming virtual games
managed to overachieve when it came to
Dead Space 1. it's easily my favorite in
the trilogy for its Incredible use of
enemy variety sound design level layout
and horror the real threat of the world
was just teased allowing those who
played the game for the story to get
excited about what's next and the
gameplay systems are well structured
enough that another game with the same
combat is more than enough reason to buy
the sequel that's the beauty of making a
stellar first impression if you manage
to nail all the aspects of your game you
can essentially copy and paste it into
the next one now doing that literally
would be met with negative reviews but
because Dead Space 1's gameplay was so
well put together the team only needs to
refine the intricacies of its design
rather than revamp the whole production
and the story left off on such good note
that the sequel can go pretty much
anywhere the team wants all that's left
is to put it together
Dead Space 2 is just as good if not
better than its predecessor the problem
that Dead Space 2 would inevitably have
to tackle is its horror the beauty of
the original came from the unknown
horror that was the Necromorphs but now
that the player has been more accustomed
to them a lot of that horror is gone the
gameplay can still be scary but the
novelty of the Necromorphs has already
faded the best way to circumvent this
issue is to create more unique monsters
or create new environments and
encounters Dead Space 2 doubles down on
both him manages to succeed the Horus
though is present is the day I stepped
onto the ishimuro which is quite hard to
pull off in a sequel with these same
horrific looking creatures Dead Space 2
succeeds though by increasing the
difficulty of the Necromorphs both in
number and in variety the tougher
enemies of Dead Space 1 are now more
common than in the previous title you
can think of Dead Space 1 and 2 as one
cohesive line of progression where the
difficulty slowly gets higher and higher
crossbow games Dead Space 2 still lets
the player get familiar with the
weaponry and mechanics early on since
some of the controls changed a bit but
the jump from weak to strong enemy seems
a lot faster in this entry as we
discussed at the end of the Dead Space 1
Section the gameplay was already
incredible so although his needed was a
level of refinement not replacement
visceral had a head start so slowly
increasing the difficulty was all that
was needed Dead Space 2 also continues
to be quite conservative with its horror
as the team knew that there was a time
and place for scares each room has more
routes for Necromorphs to come through
making it harder for the player to guess
where the creatures will spawn which is
coupled together with these specific
types of Necromorphs the new Necromorphs
this time around felt intentional in
regards to their design like for
instance these exploding babies and
Necromorph children the exploding babies
either funnel in one at a time or all at
once but they act like a slower smaller
version of the other exploding type
enemies this makes them harder to see
making it quite easy for you to be
caught off guard the Necromorph children
on the other hand only come as a group
they swarm the player and can jump over
obstacles so funneling them down a
hallway might not be possible the caveat
to both of them though is that they are
killed in one shot by far the most
annoying types of enemies in this game
are the hunters these guys hide behind
cover and stalk you until they're ready
to charge I never been more scared while
playing this game than in these sections
minus one time towards the end though
they're usually alone so another anime
these will be spawning giving you an
opportunity to only focus on the hunters
they also let out this absolutely blood
curdling scream when they charge so you
know where they are and when they're
attacking these new additions give us
the chance to Circle back to our earlier
discussion about the balance of power
and horror Dead Space 2 just by ramping
up the difficulty and increasing Enemy
Number and variety still manages to keep
that balance and I am genuinely
impressed Dead Space 1 is an excellent
example of what a survival horror game
should be but Dead Space 2 is a case
study on how to keep that Horror in
future titles the only changes Dead
Space 2 makes are with Isaac and the
game's more cinematic moments firstly is
that Isaac is now entirely voiced none
of Dead Space 2's plot has to deal with
secrecy and mystery like Nicole's true
fate so having a voice protagonist was
the right call especially in this entry
as Isaac will still continue to have
hallucinations about Nicole so being
able to hear his thoughts after knowing
the truth gives us an idea of where he's
at as a person despite what you may
think though his dialogue does not
dilute the overall experience Isaac
mostly speaks when spoken to in the
presence of another character but even
when he's alone it's only small quips
here and there it's a exactly what I
would have wanted Isaac to be like in
Dead Space 1 if they plan to give him a
voice majority of the game though he is
silent so when Necromorphs jumped from a
balcony or come from the walls he's not
gonna shout something like oh no here
they come again or time to make some
Dead Space within this room he's just
quiet it's not enough to make him feel
like he's completely silent but it's not
too much to where Isaac starts to become
irritable this restraint on making sure
Isaac doesn't monologue for three whole
minutes every minute is seen in the
action as well in order to broaden the
game's appeal the combat became more
refined and fluid and the game had more
action scenes to it such as Isaac
running away from an exploding train or
the few times you need to Jetpack past
obstacles without being hit but these
action scenes are too common though most
of the game is still running through
broken down rooms and buildings while
checking every corner in case a
Necromorph is hiding somewhere and the
devs willingness to hold back on a lot
of these new additions is commendable
and overall makes the game better but
with a new game comes a new story and
Isaac is in for quite the story the game
starts with another video of Nicole but
this time she's talking with Isaac it's
a conversation that was briefly
mentioned in the first game which shows
us that Isaac was the one one who
convinced her to join the ishimura
Nicole was originally not going to take
the job but Isaac pushed her to pursue
it anyway this is a big reason why he
feels so depressed over Nicole's death
not just because she died but because he
feels he's responsible for it the camera
pans out like in Dead Space 1 but does
stay closer to Isaac this time conveying
to the player that things are going to
get more personal this scene also shows
that not only did the game have more
time and money put into it as seen in
its graphical upgrade but also that the
devs still care about presentation the
images that show up during this
interview are not just great to look at
but is also showing us a visual
representation of Isaac's mind and how
this interview is bringing back all his
memories but right on time to drag Isaac
back to the depths of his mind Nicole
appears and starts taunting him
afterward we see Isaac in a room being
looked at by some person remember when I
talked about presentation well there
isn't a better example to show than this
Franco here is killed and immediately
transforms allowing us to see the
Necromorph transformation in real time
which is a first for the series this
intro also calls back to Dead Space 1
where Isaac is running for his life
while trying to escape the Necromorph
threat so the after is where a few
questions may arise as Isaac is being
shot at before early escaping death
again thanks to the Necromorphs this
information is tied to a few audio logs
and recordings we find shortly after
Isaac as well as a few other people were
taken to a research facility on Titan
one of Saturn's moons Titan was actually
the first rock to be Planet craft in its
Planet cracking resulted in a large
amount of the Moon being taken its
remains though were pieced together and
it's now a livable city called Titan
station or the sprawl to many of its
residents Isaac has apparently been in
this facility for three years and was
found floating in space before being
dragged here this might be related to
the hallucination he had at the end of
the first game which possibly knocked
him out but that's unclear and a bit of
stretch on my part he was taken here
initially so they could treat his
dementia as a result of the marker's
influence on him this facility has more
Sinister motivations to it though
multiple tax logs point to this facility
being secretive and off limits it's
built deep into one of the hospitals
here on Titan station so deep that none
of the staff that actually work in the
hospital can get inside half of them
probably don't even know of its
existence that's because this was a
secret facility made by earthgov in
order to find out more about the markers
some of the notes Here say that when
affected by the marker most people
experience noise but some people can see
codes and blueprints Isaac and our new
friend Nolan Strauss are two of these
people both came in contact with a
marker and were partially driven mad by
its effects but not enough for them to
be completely insane these codes and
blueprints aren't just words you can
speak and it's not something you can
explain you just know it to extract this
knowledge the people at the station
created a machine that pokes the eyes of
the participant providing those
controlling the machine with the codes
and blueprints this will allow someone
with the information to create their own
marker and as we'll soon discover
Isaac's info was already extracted and
the team was able to make their own
marker using Isaac's codes the reason
Isaac doesn't remember all of this is
because he was given memory suppressants
so he wasn't able to catch on to what
was happening to him at the facility to
make matters worse both Isaac and
Strauss are currently being hunted right
now as their key subjects the leader
behind this research Hans teedman wanted
to make sure the outbreak was contained
and that all the evidence was wiped so
killing Isaac and Strauss was one of the
steps in their plan this marker is also
how the outbreak started in the first
place we learned a bit later that when
the marker was destroyed back on ages 7
the remaining Necromorphs turned into
this soupy sludge-like consistency so it
means it's the mar marker that was
keeping them alive as you would expect
the marker here on Titan station is what
reignited the infection as various
people in the facility started feeling
nauseous while also experiencing
dementia and homicidal Tendencies just
like those on the ishimura Isaac will
eventually meet with the interviewer
Edgars who cuts him out of a
straitjacket and then kills himself as
it will also come across a laser cutter
which he Fashions into a plasma cutter
but he took a bit too long as the person
next to him was ripped to shreds as we
can see the gore has been upgraded this
time around and once again not just for
the enemies but for Isaac as well he can
still die in some pretty gruesome ways
while trying to escape the facility
Isaac receives a call from Dana who was
Allied with Franco the one who got
killed earlier she wants Isaac to meet
with her because she needs his help and
she also has a cure for his
hallucinations as a reward Isaac will
need to battle his way through countless
waves of Necromorphs and this level also
showcases the change in Pace in regards
to the outbreak with the ishimura Isaac
and the crew got there a week after so
the infection had time to develop in
Fester but on Titan station it's
happening right now Isaac is in the
middle of the outbreak in the
environment in combat reflect this
Necromorphs are showing up in all-time
types of places like on the balconies in
people's rooms and the people in these
rooms are either dead going to die or
not trying to die there's a couple that
is running away from what I assume is
one of their parents judging from the
dialogue and quite a few people can be
heard screaming and crying inside the
rooms either because they think
someone's trying to get in or it's
already in
my father
all right
let's see
oh my God
it's horrifying and really matches the
tone of what's going on people are
scared and worried that they or their
loved ones will be dead so they're all
trying to escape and this causes mass
panic entrances are blocked off or
sealed trains are being bordered by not
just people but also Necromorphs as well
and there's a high chance that 99 of the
population on the station is going to
die after getting through the chaos the
tone settles down a bit and goes back to
the 10th Slow Burn atmosphere that we're
familiar with as Isaac is now alone and
has to take quite a long detour through
an unexpected building Isaac has to cut
through a unitology building to get to
Dana and I cannot express you how
excited I was to hear that I can only
imagine how much Allure I was going to
find here and I was not disappointed to
get through here Isaac has to go through
one of the introduction hauls before
making it to the core of the facility
where people can take tours and see what
unitology is about there are dozens of
text logs voice recordings speeches and
promotional footage that we can find
throughout this building so instead of
just going through it chronologically
let me just summarize it on a more
digestible fashion apparently unitology
at least the facility here on Titan
station is struggling with recruiting
new members their Arch Enemy earthgov
made a smear campaign recently against
them causing the group to to lose some
public opinion also due to CEC layoffs
they haven't been able to put
unitologists in key positions like how
some of the crew on the ishimura were
unitologists due to the outbreak on the
ishimura planet cracking activity has
slowed down to a halt unemployment Rose
to 9.5 percent on Titan station and any
business related to Planet cracking like
Dock Workers mining suppliers and Tool
vendors have all suffered heavy losses
financially the CEC seems to be okay but
they can't earn much profit because they
can't go on planet cracking operations
which means that the unitologist can't
be a part of the planet cracking crew
like in the ishimura speaking of that
and we'll discover this later but I feel
like I should mention it now only Isaac
knows the true fate of the ishimura as
Ellie a character who we'll also meet
later claims that the official news
report says that terrorists killed
everyone on the ishimura which we of
course know is untrue Isaac ends up
making it to a residential section of
the facility and this whole location I
found quite fascinating this seems to be
inside the actual building itself and
not just another residential area like
we saw earlier so these people seem to
be living together which doesn't really
help with the whole cult Vibe unitology
gives off in these areas are hundreds of
writings on the wall in unitology
scripture and a few statues of the
marker it's kind of crazy to think about
how some people might be living
underneath all of this considering how
tightly packed the station is in these
rooms is where Isaac will get one of the
first hallucinations of Nicole it seems
that the marker still has an influence
on him but he is still very resilient as
Isaac knows that Nicole is not real
after this we enter a large hallway with
six presentations detailing the
beginnings of unitology as we know
unitology started when Michael Altman
found the black marker on Earth which we
now know was located near the Yucatan
Peninsula according to unitology the
markers spoke to Altman spoke luckily
means that Altman is like Isaac and
Strauss beings who have codes and
blueprints in their brains thanks to the
marker's influence unitology claims that
the marker spoke to all men about the
unity of mankind towards a bright and
better future after this Michael Alden
was assassinated because he spoke about
the marker not because he was some
religious zealot but because the
government didn't want knowledge of the
marker to reach the public that's why
everyone in unitology sees Altman as a
martyr for the church because he was
killed for speaking the truth all but
never wanted to be a unitologist in fact
he is a member nor the creator of it he
was just a researcher who found the
marker first and wanted to share his
Discovery with the world but the people
took this in a different way that he had
intended unitology believes that he is a
messiah when he was really just a
researcher churches then began to start
up everywhere with the one here on Titan
station being one of the largest in the
solar system the final presentation
talks about what they refer to as the
convergence this is what that uniting of
all mankind will lead to so for them
it's the final step of unitology we have
to remember though that the marker
creates the Necromorph so all this
information is skewed and incorrect
being united in death isn't some
Heavenly thing that occurs when the time
comes they'll literally be United by
dying and becoming Necromorphs as for
what the convergence event leads to
though well that's for Dead Space 3 to
explain one thing I enjoy about these
presentations is how they utilize the
unreliable narrator Trope a lot of this
information is kind of wrong as we just
discussed and it makes unitology seem
more pleasant than it actually is after
that hallway we enter another main room
in the church where the tour of
unitology begins Dana also says that
Isaac needs to go through here and take
an elevator to the top as she's hiding
in one of the safe rooms at the top of
the church this whole chapter is a
metaphor as Isaac is following the route
the tour guides would use and he's also
going into restricted areas throughout
the building so he's metaphorically
going through the process of being a
unitologist from their initiation to
their cleansing most of the tour only
shows what the church wants you to see
like the library and sermon rooms but I
actually have to stop and laugh at one
of the rooms names because it was called
indoctrination and its description is
about as ironic as you can get with a
name like that
welcome to indoctrination the church
seminar is currently in progress please
wait for the next available Church
associate indoctrination is a pleasant
joyous event where you will take the
first steps into glorious Oneness that
is unitology
these unitologists are either so dense
that this blue right past them are the
most intelligent people in the world
they use the word indoctrination as a
sort of a playful term when they're
literally indoctrinating people into
believing their beliefs the hilarity of
this organization continues into the
next room where participants are taken
to a back room so the church can assess
them and at the top is a list of results
regarding the person's self-confidence
susceptibility to translate States and
gullibility this is also a good time to
talk about Isaac's hallucinations
because right after Nicole appears and
tries to stab him with a syringe if you
succeed then it's revealed that Isaac
was trying to kill himself if you fail
Nicole will stab and kill Isaac with
this needle but since she's not there it
would look like Isaac killed himself if
someone were to watch him the same thing
happens later towards the end of the
game where it failed Isaac will Harpoon
himself with a javelin gun so it seems
like the marker cannot only toy with him
but also has some physical control over
him to an extent Dana then hops on the
comms again and tells Isaac to take the
elevator up and it's very important that
he goes up because if he goes down that
leads to the Crypt a very important step
in unitology is death because members
who remain untouched and clean can join
in the unification that happens after
to preserve the body members are not
allowed to be cremated or buried and
must be kept in these ice-cold crowd
chambers that the body doesn't decompose
all these people will then live on after
death reunification when the convergence
event starts it's fascinating to see
this Dynamic within the church as it's
clear not everyone is on the same page
there was an article in Dead Space one
that talked about someone infiltrating
the ranks of unitology but couldn't
uncover much since a lot of their
rituals and what they entail were quite
low-key it's also confirmed that not
everyone knows about the Necromorphs
because Dr Mercer was able to create his
own and willingly accepted one before he
died but if this Necromorph infection
was told to everyone then more people
would know about the outbreak plus not
once is the word Necromorph or anything
like that ever mentioned during the tour
from an outsider's perspective it would
seem like the convergence means all
humans are unified and spirit formed
together when in actuality they're just
used to create Necromorphs which then
lead to the convergence event once
enough Necromorphs are within the
presence of the marker this is sadly the
last piece of info we will get to learn
on this wonderful tour through this
decrepit Palace but the Lord that is
learned here is incredible unitology was
a mystery for a while and Dead Space 2
did exactly what I wanted it to do which
which it was take the general idea of
the previous game and expand on it and
what's better than letting us walk
through an entire church for two whole
hours throughout this journey Isaac has
had to deal with swarms of Necromorphs
and this is also around the time I came
to appreciate two specific things one
was at the standard Necromorphs actually
changed clothing depending on the
location as in here any regular
nekamorphs wear priest clothing where
during the initial outbreak most had
regular clothes on the other was the
actual design of the church itself I
have no idea if there's a specific name
for this but the only thing I could come
up with was a mix of religious brutalism
it's got the stained glass style of a
normal church but has a mix of gold and
black colors along with the sharp Jagged
designs on the floors and walls and it
makes it seem even more Sinister and
given what unitology is about Sinister
sounds about right Isaac will then
finally make it to the top of the church
and if you've been confused as to how
this woman made it to the top of the
church considering how far deep into the
church this is then you're catching on
as Dana is a unitologist there was never
actually a cure she was just tricking
Isaac which makes her the third person
to betray him right behind Kendra and
fake Nicole earthgrove one of the key
subjects like Isaac dead because they
assume that he would destroy the marker
which obviously Isaac would do but Dana
however wants Isaac alive so he can do
the opposite they want Isaac to build
more markers for unitology allowing them
to spread convergence across the Galaxy
just as quickly she arrives on screen is
about as quickly she disappears though
as tiedeman's goons find Isaac and
decimate the room this is where some of
those action scenes come in that we
talked about as Isaac is almost sucked
out of the building while also getting
shot at by some guys who have some of
the worst aim I have ever seen to which
Isaac escapes but not before getting
involved with the Gunship again and a
large Necromorph which flings him out of
the building even though this scene
flings the game's genre lever from
horror to action immediately I did enjoy
the presentation of it at least like I
said these aren't as common as you would
think though because you have to
remember we just walked through a church
for almost two hours so two minutes of
action for two hours of Horrors fine by
me after this is what I like to call Act
2 which is just chapters 6 through 10.
it's probably the weakest act in the
game story wise but the reason I say
this is because a lot of this act
focuses on the gameplay as the story is
practically non-existent which I guess
coming off a very story driven Act is a
nice way to balance things out most of
of the actors centered around Isaac
meeting up with Strauss who ends up
meeting up with Ellie so it's really
just Isaac Ellie and Strauss trying to
meet each other Strauss also believes
that there's a way to destroy the marker
and that it's located in the government
sector of the station Joss claims that
there are also four steps to the process
but a lot of that isn't clear until much
later the reason Strauss is here is tied
to Dead Space aftermath an animated
feature that details the events between
the two games after the market was
destroyed on ages 7 the USG Bannon was
commissioned to go to the impact site
and retrieve any fragments they could
Strauss was on that ship and because he
came in contact with the marker even if
it was just a fragment of it he ended up
seeing hallucinations like Isaac he
ended up getting worse and worse until
one day he snapped and killed his wife
and child that's why Strauss mentions
his wife and son a lot when talking to
him and why he often loses his train of
thought when the two talk because he's
seeing a hallucination of them on the
way to the government sector Isaac will
meet with Ellie who nearly misses his
skull basically all we learned from her
is that she was the last of her Squad as
they were all killed on the way to the
government sector so Ellie is doing her
best to keep it together despite being
the only one who lived one thing that's
great though is that over time the two
will get more comfortable with one
another and will occasionally joke
around a bit to get to the government
sector Isaac will need to get to the
transport Hub which requires him to pass
by the elementary school on its own it's
quite terrifying to see mutant children
walking around trying to kill you which
you also have to consider that they were
killed by Necromorphs and trying to
imagine a swarm of them cornering a
school full of children is probably
something I should stop thinking about
isaacanelli then meets but even cuts off
the power so the two need to turn the
power back on in order to get the train
running so they can make it to the
government sector get used to this
backtracking and lack of progression as
it continues for quite a bit we don't
reach the government sector until
chapter 12 and we're currently on
chapter six so we have roughly another
three hours or so before we actually
make it the only thing of note that
occurs in these levels is the mental
downfall of Strauss as he's going more
insane the longer the game goes on this
reaches two specific boiling points
where he stabs Ellie's eye out before
getting knocked upside the head by her
and then he attacks Isaac with the same
weapon to which Isaac is forced to take
him down Isaac has been through a lot
during these two games and having to Now
kill someone who I would consider to be
the only person who truly understands
Isaac is heartbreaking for him no one
will ever understand this severity of
the marker and being forced to take
drugs in order to become complacent
Strauss was able to share that grief
with him but he wasn't able to overcome
it like Isaac was to an extent Isaac
hasn't really been able to overcome it
either but he's in a much better
headspace than Strauss was in oddly
enough the main plots of this act is
about Isaac overcoming his grief but his
circumstances won't make it any easier
as while trying to make it to the
government sector he'll have to go back
to his own personal hell
oh my God
that's the shamura the ishimura is back
and with it comes all of Isaac's
memories everything that happened aboard
that ship is still living with him the
death of Nicole the outbreak the
betrayals all of it is still there and
it's this acknowledgment of his past
that makes this the best chapter in The
Game chapter 10 starts exactly the same
as dead space 1. in fact the majority of
the rooms in this chapter will feel very
familiar to you both Isaac and the
player have history here you know what
happened here and you know they could
still be here this whole chapter is a
slow burn kind of horror there's a slow
build up that keeps going and going
until it finally bursts from the
entrance of the ship to the first enemy
was a whole 11 minutes of walking
everything is quiet and terrifying
because you know that they're still here
but you don't know where and the game
starts the bursting of the combat with a
jump scare and puts you against one of
the strongest enemies in the game this
quiet atmosphere also played into the
Mind Games of this level you cross
through so many familiar areas and yet
nothing happens no jump scare by the
first elevator no Ambush by the
decontamination room and the one time
you guessed correctly they still get you
the room where Isaac strived across the
floor still has the same technical
monster Untold surveilled that it's just
a hallucination Isaac like the player
remembers this encounter and knew this
was coming it was only a matter of time
this one scene also shows how much of
Isaac and even the player's mind is
still stuck here invisible knew you and
Isaac would remember this so they played
into those memories which is how the
ishimura the second time Iran still felt
as terrifying as the first it's also
here where Isaac gets a lot of his
hallucinations and even has to re-watch
the same video of Nicole that we saw at
the end of the first game Isaac is still
coming to terms at Nicole's death and
it's hard to blame him Isaac pushed for
Nicole to do this job and that decision
would eventually lead to her death
obviously Isaac didn't kill her but it's
clear why he would feel like he had a
hand in it he also has to see her all
the time in hundreds of hallucinations
and was drugged for quite some time so
he never had time to reflect and move on
even though Isaac physically disappeared
for three years in between games his
mind traveled as fast as we did when we
played them back to back Nicole's death
still feels fresh to him which still
makes it harder for him to come to terms
of it and move on it's not like it was a
breakup they were in love and deeply
committed to one another until an
outside Source ruined what they had so
it's not just the fact that Nicole and
him aren't in a relationship but also
the fact that she is no longer here to
begin with that's why the marker is
trying so hard to ruin Isaac using
Nicole she was the most important person
in his life at the time and now she's
dead and not only will he never see her
again he'll have to be reminded of her
death every day this culminates in the
next encounter where Isaac and fake
Nicole talk about Isaac and why he's
still fighting this Isaac admits that he
couldn't accept that she was dead
because she was the only thing that
mattered to him Nicole then becomes a
less threatening version and says the
final step to defeating the marker was
acceptance these steps are tied to that
device we briefly mentioned which is how
the research team extracted the codes
from Isaac it's not that he needs to do
this in order to enter the device but
it's so he can move on and focus on
what's important he can't let Nicole's
fate drag him down and he has to move on
and destroy the marker or none of this
will matter this interaction and
acceptance as to why he was so broken up
over Nicole's death means that Isaac now
has a clear mind allowing him to focus
on the main objective the next sequence
of events which starts with an ambush on
a moving drill is also the start of act
3 whereas act 1 was more story focused
and act 2 was more combat focused act 3
is a mix of both and is a good way to
end the game a lot of the bands are
between these two lovebirds also comes
out because you can tell they both end
enjoy each other's company but they just
don't want to admit it it doesn't
recognize the new Junction I think I've
got it from up here
what I didn't hear you
I did it I got it started there you know
there's a lift on the other side I'll
turn around you can get on
CE they arrive at the government sector
Isaac and Ellie find a ship and Isaac
locks her in the ship and forces Ellie
to escape so Isaac can finish this
himself Isaac plans to die here he has
no plans of coming back so he wants
Ellie to get out safely this also
showcases the beauty of the wriglings
that have occurred throughout the series
as you can see Ellie is literally
talking into the camera in the
background I've always liked the small
detail because everything that happened
in the rig link is shown in game which
is a nice touch as Isaac sends Ellie on
her way Isaac and Nicole get some time
to talk and it's here where things start
to really settle in as Nicole says the
infamous line make us whole even though
Nicole is nicer now it's still a
creation of the marker before Isaac can
get to said marker he's ambushed by some
of the Teen men's guards Isaac doesn't
fight them though as he instead shuts
off the power which lets in all the
Necromorphs plus visceral likely knew
the combat against enemies with guns
wouldn't be fun and definitely would not
do this in the sequel inside this
building is where a bit more lore is
placed in regards to the marker's
creation it's not much but according to
some of the log it seems like the
process of creating the marker was
relatively easy once they understood it
one researcher even claimed that it was
like the marker wanted them to succeed
in creating it obviously we know what
the creation of the markers leads to so
it would make sense that the process to
create one is very easy because the more
markers that exist the faster and
farther the outbreak can spread as we
approach the core we can see the
Necromorphs in the distance walking
towards our objective which we discover
is the site 12 marker furthermore
because Isaac shot off the power and let
them inside he also unknowingly started
a convergence event demon is
disappointed in Isaac for ruining his
plan because Steven was trying to
understand the marker the markers give
off Limitless amounts of energy and
seeing as Humanity was in the verge of
collapsing due to a lack of resources
one unlimited resource would be a big
help demon was likely trying to
understand its effects because he and
probably many others than Earth gov
believe that the markers can be used to
sustain humanity and prevent them from
dying out but we know that the markers
don't work that way now the convergence
event is underway the end of the world
is about to begin unless Isaac can stop
it to stop it Isaac needs to step into
the machine so that he can be accepted
by the marker Nicole claims that this
machine threatens the marker because
it's afraid of Isaac and Nicole working
together this is a complete lie as after
skewing Demon's head Isaac is betrayed
by Nicole again this machine was used by
Eisen before but it seems like him
accepting Nicole's death changes things
as the marker was able to gain more
control over his brain it wouldn't make
sense otherwise because this is a
necessary step to defeating the marker
once inside this marker dream realm
Isaac has to fight off Nicole and
destroy the marker the reason Isaac is
being killed is because two complete the
convergence event the maker must be
sacrificed and since Isaac technically
made it thanks to T been using the codes
in his mind he is the maker destroying
the marker in the dream realm also
destroys the marker in the real world
most likely because Isaac is the maker
of the marker so he has the power to do
that in this dream realm Isaac has now
finished his mission and can finally die
in peace the credits even start rolling
to show that this is really the end
until Ellie hops on the rig Lincoln says
that she's going to crash the building
to get him obviously Isaac wanted it to
end here but now that she's going to get
him it would be quite rude if he ignored
her plus she could die here as well so
he enters the gunship and the two
survive as a nice little treat the game
recreates the final scene from the first
game with Isaac looking over at the
passenger seat but this time it's just
Ellie and not a hallucination Dead Space
2 for all the obstacles that had to
overcome managed to go right through
them with ease and needed to ramp up the
horror and power while also striking a
balance between its action and horror on
top of creating an engaging story with
new lore and characters and manage to
pull it all off it really is a miracle
that Not much went wrong with this game
as it could have gone in the complete
opposite direction but the team behind
the helm knew what to do and how to do
it right it's a complete Dead Space
experience that had everything go right
well not everything despite how
impressive Dead Space 2 is the same
cannot be said for its DLC severed
severed might be the most peculiar
content I have ever played everything
from the actual content to its
manufacturing is just strange and I
cannot for the life of me figure out why
this DLC was made firstly this DLC is
for PS3 and Xbox 360. despite the fact
that Dead Space 2 launched on Steam day
one this DLC is nowhere to be seen on
the platform furthermore due to
PlayStation continuing to cause me and
menstruous over what games are actually
backwards compatible with in their
catalog this game is only available on
the PS3 Dead Space 2 nor severed are on
the PS4 or 5. the only console that wins
is Xbox is you can play this on the 360
one or series X and S like I have on
release it was already alienating part
of its audience and now in the modern
day barely anyone can actually play it
that's not only strange on its own but
when you consider that the company
behind this game is EA of all people
that is even stranger the next part is
the story and gameplay several two main
characters are gay Weller and lexine
Murdoch characters you won't recognize
unless you played the Wii title Dead
Space extraction Gabe isama made it to
Titan station and his whole journey is
just trying to get lexine off the
station before the outbreak kills them
both dead space extraction was released
on the Wii but was ported to the PS3
when Dead Space 2 released probably
because they had planned on this DLC
from the start now you could say
extraction isn't necessary for this DLC
but I would argue against that claim
because extraction does more to
characterize Gabe and Lexi and then
severed ever does to give you a brief
idea of the game extraction takes place
on ages 7 during the outbreak and you go
from the planet to the ishimura
throughout that game this provides a lot
of context regarding Gabe and lexine's
journey and why at the beginning Gabe
messages are saying that they're back
because the two are familiar with the
Necromorphs this DLC however doesn't add
much because it is short like extremely
short it takes about 60 to 90 minutes to
complete the whole thing so where in
this short time frame are you going to
fit anything about these two in fact
none of the events of extraction are
even referenced in this game the whole
plot of the DLC is that the outbreak on
Titan station has started and Gabe wants
Alexian to get to the shuttle they have
the only problem is that lexian like
Isaac is a key subject so she's going to
be killed this leads into a 50-minute
gameplay sequence where gay brushes
through the first chapter of the main
game in order to find her before his
Squad made victas because he plans to
follow his orders and kill her Vic
actually attempts to kill Gabe earlier
because they work together and thus have
the same order and Vic knows Gabe
wouldn't shoot his own wife to which he
says Gabe I don't want this any more
than you do but the difference between
you and me is that when an order comes
through I follow it this implies that if
Vic was told to kill his own wife by
someone higher in the chain of command
he would do it I pray this man isn't
married on top of this the gameplay Loop
of using credits to buy items from the
store and operating abilities with the
power nodes is still the same and
severed as it is in the main game but
Dead Space 2 is a 7 to 8 Hour game
severed is 60 minutes there's not nearly
enough time to actually invest in power
notes for upgrades and not even enough
money to actually feel pleased with your
purchase since you likely won't get that
money back severt also cannot be played
on New Game Plus so it's not like you
can carry over the few stats you put
into the game which makes me wonder why
they were even added to begin with this
decision inadvertently raises the
difficulty by King even the gameplay
this way because you're essentially
fighting chapter 13 style enemies is a
chapter 2 Isaac you are drastically
underpowered for these encounters and it
makes things feel way worse I died more
times than I thought during this DLC and
ran out of ammo more times than I could
count because the enemy numbers never
let up all of this culminates to the
strangest ending in the strangest DLC
I've ever played
look you were both being played the
whole time
all they needed you for was to get her
pregnant what but now you're just
security risks I'm sorry Gabe what is
Right Gabe because I said the same thing
when I heard that as well vaccine on
occasion will call Gabe and tell him
that these men in white are looking for
her these men in white are seen
cornering Vic before killing him and
then taking lexine Gabe then Sprints
after her kills them because they become
Necromorph shortly after gets blown up
by a grenade because Vic isn't actually
dead and now has to shoot the blast door
so Lexing can escape while Gabe bleeds
on the floor this ending did tug at the
heartstrings a bit but there's so many
Loose Ends Here what happened to lexine
who were the men in white what's the
Oracle program I know we haven't talked
about Dead Space 3 but I can assure you
none of this is answered the only detail
that is mentioned in this is the men in
White in a novel called Dead Space
Salvage apparently these guys are
oracles which would tie them to the
aforementioned Oracle program but the
oracles don't seem to be mentioned much
in Salvage and seems to just be a bunch
of secretive people within earthgov or
possibly unitology as they carry out
orders of the highest importance and the
Oracle program doesn't actually get
mentioned it's likely tied to the marker
and its effects on childbirth which is
admittedly a cool plot to go into if
they had actually done something with it
so to actually understand the full story
of Gabe and Lexi and you'll need to play
dead space extraction severed and then
read Salvage for the last bit at the end
and that just doesn't seem remotely
satisfying to me and that's my main
complaint I've thought for longer than I
played this DLC on why this was made and
I came to two conclusions it was either
for fans of extraction or to get fans to
play extraction I can't imagine it was
the former though there aren't any stats
nowadays but extraction arm release did
not sell well at all probably because it
was a non-rail shooter for the Wii that
spawned from a third person horror
shooter on a console and PC this isn't
something like Ghost of Sparta for God
of War where it was essentially the same
kind of game but portable this is a
complete 180 from the original design I
can't imagine there was that big of a
crowd of people that played and liked
extraction enough back then for visceral
to make a DLC that would appease them so
my only consensus is that it's the
latter for people who played severed
first and wanted to know more about Gabe
and lexine out of the two options this
one sounds much better but the problem
is that sever does a terrible job
characterizing Gabe without the context
of extraction he seems like a security
guard who just tried to save his wife
and died doing so and it's due to this
and the lack of time with Gabe that it
makes it really hard to justify buying
extraction assuming you can even deduce
that he was from extraction as it's
never mentioned anywhere so unless you
played extraction or looked him up you
wouldn't know not even the description
of the Xbox Marketplace points to gay
being a familiar character within the
dead space cannon and not just some
random character they made for the DLC
like I said it is the strangest thing I
have ever played because I do not know
why this was made Dead Space is an
incredible game severed is not but I can
recognize that things could have been
incredible had some certain decisions
been made despite that though the main
game is really what's important and Dead
Space 2 is made with some impeccable
quality despite reusing the same enemies
in combat design the horror of Dead
Space 2 is just as good as the original
it even managed to throw the player back
into one of the most familiar areas in
the series and it was still terrifying
to walk through the balance between
horror and gameplay was great and never
felt off in any way and the Very risky
decision of letting Isaac talk and more
of a focus on action more carefully
crafted to make sure it was included
when never overstepped its bounds the
Dead Space series started off on the
right foot and has continued to do so up
until now so let's see if they can keep
it going for one more game
Dead Space 3's design is about as
divergent from an original work as you
can get just about everything has
changed from story to length to gameplay
Deadspace 3 is an evolution of the
series but it's just about as
interesting as unitology's idea of an
evolution Dead Space 3 bothers me
greatly because there's so many things I
hate about this game but there's so many
things I love about it Dead Space 3
starts with Isaac getting jumped in his
apartment by two people Carver and
Norton they need Isaac's help because
Ellie's gone missing while in search for
a way to stop the markers and they need
Isaac to help find Ellie and destroy the
markers Isaac claims that he's done with
that life and wants to lay low but he
doesn't have a choice he's got a gun to
his head for one but also because the
unitologists have made their move
they're here to kill Isaac and they will
blow up a city block in order to do so
this action doesn't seem to let up
either as our first enemy encounter in
this game is a good old-fashioned
shootout this makes no sense to me I can
admit that it was only a matter of time
before unitology launched a full-scale
war and we're likely going to fight
Isaac but it still doesn't make the gun
play any interesting Dead Space was
never designed to be an action and
that's the first problem the core
gameplay is still the same but the
gameplay was made for a survival horror
game so its attempt at keeping the
horror is holding back the action but
the action is holding back the horror by
going way over the top with its
explosions and set pieces so we have
both systems at war with one another and
neither of them are letting up so where
does that leave Dead Space 3. honestly I
don't actually know it's a horror game
without the horror in an action game
which is the bare amount of systems tied
to it because Dead Space 3 is still a
horror game so it's neither it's just a
game a game with no substance and no
personality shortly after the shootouts
Isaac is captured by Jacob danik a
leader within unitology who not only
wants to kill Isaac but also keep him
alive long enough to witness the marker
activating I honestly thought he was
full of [ __ ] and then he actually did it
we're only 15 minutes into the game and
a marker has been activated at least the
gameplay will go back to Necromorphs
though but not quite the Necromorphs are
present but not really the main enemy we
will be fighting is zombies they are
technically Necro morphs but let's be
honest they are very zombie-like I find
this strange as most horror games
struggle to find a unique monster to use
so they default to zombies because it's
familiar Dead Space has been anything
but familiar yet it still goes back to
the basics of horror this is the same
game that has dozens of different types
of disgusting creatures made from the
repurposed flesh of the human it just
killed and it thought zombies would be
what we wanted to fight first it's
strange just as strange as the pace of
combat Dead Space 2 ramped up the
difficulty by making the harder enemies
appear earlier along with the addition
of different types of enemies per
encounter Dead Space 3 just decided to
add more encounters that are separated
by about one hallway of breathing room
more enemies in those encounters and
faster movement speed it's such a simple
method of adding difficulty but it's not
even that bad if you play it right and I
couldn't this is because of Dead Space
3's biggest change co-op in Dead Space 3
you and a friend can now fight their
Necromorphs together with player 2 as
John Carver but don't get too familiar
with him because at least for this video
you won't be hearing about him much
that's because Dead Space 3's Co-op is
incredibly flawed despite the team
admitting that they copied re4 they
apparently stopped there and didn't even
bother taking notes from re5 Dead Space
3 allows the player to play solo if they
want to do not do this it is the single
worst decision you can make in this game
Dead Space 3 is not a solo game with a
co-op mode it's the opposite enemies are
balanced around Co-op meaning they are
much faster and come in such large
numbers that it would prove challenging
for a team of two but this balance stays
in Solo which means you're now fighting
double the enemies with double the speed
alone this wouldn't be half as bad if
Carver existed but they opted to just
take him out of the game for 95 of its
run time Carver is an integral part of
the game and story it's the main reason
Co-op was made to begin with and yet
they decided to just omit him from the
game entirely if you decide to play
alone Resident Evil 5 used cheva as an
AI teammate yeah she wasn't great and
she was much better in the hands of a
player but at least she was there this
is what leads me to believe that just
like the horror in action the people who
made the solo and Co-op parts of the
game are constantly at battle with one
another in Co-op Carver is present for
all the cutscenes but in Solo he's only
there for the important ones but instead
of sticking with one plan the two sides
just compromised because Carver isn't in
some scenes for Solo in Co-op he doesn't
speak for example in this scene Carver
is present in both solo and in Co-op so
he has dialogue but in this one where
they're in an elevator cover doesn't
appear in Solo so in Co-op he doesn't
speak it's like the team wanted to
reward the player for playing Co-op by
giving them the ability to play as
Carver but they also wanted to lessen
the blow as much as possible so they
opted to make Carver not have any lines
that the solo players don't miss
anything furthermore because Carver
isn't in Solo the team has to write some
reason as to why he leaves like towards
the end where the two are rushing to a
thing called the machine in the cutscene
the two talk and decide that they're
going to do what's right and do it
together then literally seconds after
this Carver goes up to a walkway and the
floor collapses so now cover and Isaac
have to split up the game does this
constantly because the story is supposed
to include the two of them but because
solo only includes Isaac Carver only
shows up momentarily then splits up
right after it's even worse when it's
the opposite than it goes from combat a
cutscene because Carver will always just
show up despite being nowhere near you
the entire time this problem also
extends to the story since he doesn't
appear we never learn about him and his
characterization is so jarring that you
would think someone else was writing the
story Carver doesn't care about Isaac's
life his problems are really anything
about him he's just here for the mission
the two get into arguments quite a bit
and it never seems like they'll make up
until the last hour of the game where
the two have a heart to heart before the
final battle this is because of the four
Co-op only missions that have Carver
confront his past the same way Isaac did
in Dead Space too allowing Carver to see
the bigger picture and realize he can't
do this alone not only will solo players
never see this but because Dead Space 3
has asymmetrical Co-op only Carver will
see it because while he's in a dream
sequence fighting off his own mind Isaac
is tasked with defending him in the
hallway that he's standing in outside of
this their Brotherhood is developing
throughout the game by having Carver
rely on Isaac to fight the never-ending
hordes of Necromorphs the same way Isaac
relies on him Co-op will likely be
played with a friend so while you two
are covering each other and working
together so too are Isaac and Carver and
those two end up becoming friends
because of
in Solo though he's just a guy it's a
complete 180 and it also makes no sense
anyway because it's supposed to be this
whole conversation about Isaac and
Carver doing it together and talking
about how if one of them falls together
we'll get the job done for them because
they realize they need each other yet
right after this the two split up and
Isaac does everything himself because
Carver can't be in the solo campaign at
this point I feel like it was more work
to try and walk around the issue than to
just add him as an AI companion it would
have at least made the game more
interesting Co-op not only causes issues
for the solo player by removing Carver
but it also makes the gameplay more
difficult because it's supposed to be
played in Co-op however there is a
pleasant catch to all of this even if
this also comes with its own issues
every Necromorph drops ammo and
resources like usual but since the enemy
numbers are doubled you are now given
double the items I cannot remember a
single time in this game I ran out of
ammo or medkits I had more items that I
knew what to do with and this is also
because of the next change and that's
ammo Dead Space 3 has a crafting bench
allowing you to craft your own Weapon by
making a top and bottom Barrel that's
fitted with some type of device this is
a supposed to be a play on Isaac's
engineering expertise and I don't mind
it in fact some of the tools are based
on older weapons but this ends up
creating a problem as the game now has
to balance all ammo types leading to
less ammo for all the guns you actually
have to circumvent this problem they
just made all weapons share the same
ammo now called ammo Clips if you apply
the system to what we just talked about
your inventory will look something like
this even though my ammo is three slots
large that's actually quite a lot as
each weapon uses different amounts of
ammo Rockets use more ammo per shot than
an assault rifle and that on screen is
500 rounds of assault rifle ammo all
within three Slots of inventory these
are problems on their own but when
they're all combined together it makes
it a mess very early on in chapter 6 I
had over 1 000 rounds of ammo and I was
so overpowered that I not only
dismantled all the powerful parts of my
gun but turned the game up to hard but
this also became a problem as the enemy
numbers are still doubled so now I'm
being swarmed in seconds I flop back
between normal and hard countless times
using different kinds of guns and
strategies and not a single one felt
satisfying Dead Space 3 finally runs in
to the problem we've discussed in this
video the game has an imbalance of power
and horror there is little to no actual
Terror in this game so you start
questioning whether or not you're
playing a horror game and the gameplay
either makes you overpowered or
underpowered squandering any chance you
could have had to create tension Dead
Space 3 is trying so hard to appeal to
horror and action fans while also
appealing to those who play solo or
Co-op and in trying to please everyone
and ended up pleasing no one
so the game plays a wash what about the
story surprisingly not too bad Dead
Space 3 has a pretty decent beginning
and awful middle and a fantastic ending
the story was the only reason I was able
to make it through the game and I was
happy that at least some of the time I
spent was worth it to pick up where we
left off Norton and Carver recruit Isaac
for their mission to find Ellie and
destroy the markers Carver and Isaac get
captured by danik who then releases a
Necromorph Outbreak on the moon the
reason he did all this was not only to
spread the outbreak and kill Isaac
because he is the marker killer after
all but because danik sees what Earth
gov did with the markers as heresy he
believes that Earth gov experimenting on
them is going against their religion so
he launched an attack against them and
activated the marker markers activating
like this isn't out of the ordinary
Isaac did it on accident back on ages 7
but this instant infection is odd this
has never happened before and it was
never mentioned that such a thing could
actually happen the markers have two
methods of attack that contribute to the
outbreak it first starts with dementia
and hallucinations this will then
progress to homicidal Tendencies which
is paired with the next step and that's
the dead tissue that is changed by the
marker which creates the Necromorphs
once the first Necromorph is made it's
pretty much a done deal at this point as
the infection will spread pretty rapidly
this is a slow process and is intended
to be but this just happens immediately
it doesn't connect with any of the lore
that we're familiar with secondly
everyone in the game seems to forget
this event ever happened danik released
an outbreak on the moon the closest
piece of rock to Earth and yet not only
does no one mention this to anyone or
even radio Earth about it Norton even
talks about going back once the
mission's done even worse Norton says
he's the last of Earth gov meaning that
Earth gov is gone and was likely killed
off by danik and his army danik also
says that markers like these are
everywhere on all the major colonies and
outposts so does Earth have some too and
furthermore since earthgov is gone does
that mean danik launched an outbreak on
Earth it's never explained but all we do
know is that danik released an outbreak
on the moon so I have to ask back where
Norton the Moon is gone by now we have
seen twice by now that once the outbreak
starts it won't stop even though Isaac
defeated both markers at ages 7 in Titan
stage that was also after all or almost
all the population was dead that's the
horror of an outbreak once it starts it
won't stop so how does no one realize
that danik literally just doomed the
whole Moon people are shocked sure but
it's more about danik just using the
marker to create Necromorphs not the
fact that he just triggered one on the
moon next to Earth you know the home
world above Humanity after this is where
we get introduced to the zombie-like
necro morphs and for the life of me I
cannot figure out how they were created
most of the Necromorphs are the same way
but they at least have some differences
between them believe the children are
different from the regular Necromorphs
one was likely a child and the other an
adult but the zombie-like enemies and
the standard Necromorph seem to have no
differences biologically so how were
they created what part of their biology
makes one different from the other I
never ended up figuring this out and I
was reminded of this the whole game
because Dead Space 3 really loves to
throw these enemies at you and that's
another part I found rather confusing
Dead Space 3 has so many Necromorphs to
work with yet ninety percent of the
encounters are just the same humanoid
version The Tubby looking enemies only
show up a handful of times the in fact
factors that create more Necromorphs the
brutes with the plate-like armor and the
dividers which are the ones that spawn
those moving skulls and the Necromorph
children are completely gone one of the
more unique enemies the ones that stuck
to the wall were present but gutted in
this release these two spit pods out
that would act as another layer of
complexity to the fight Dead Space 3
removed these entirely I sat here for
three whole minutes and nothing happened
it's not the fact that Dead Space 3 had
nothing to work with it's the fact that
they had the opportunity to put these in
the game and purposely refused the only
new creatures in this game are these
immune Necromorphs which is really just
a riff on the old ones from the previous
games they just look a bit different the
zombies the skinny looking enemies
called feeders that are really just the
kids from Dead Space 2 but grown up and
just as weak and the moving skull enemy
again but this time taking control of
dead corpses with guns that shoot at you
there was only one genuinely great
Necromorph way later in the game that is
100 unique but we'll have to talk about
them later all these editions are just
so unimaginative and it's a complete
regression from the level of creativity
the first games had but wouldn't it make
sense that now of all games would be the
game to include them fighting a brute
alongside other enemies would make sense
for two people to do so so why not
commit to it Dead Space 3 has some
serious commitment issues because it
doesn't know what it wants to do so it
just goes halfway on everything and this
must have rubbed off on the cast because
Ellie also has some commitment issues
that need sorting we learn in the same
breath that Isaac and Ellie got together
and broke up her new boyfriend is
Captain Robert Norton although I'm
inclined to call him Captain cuck
because this man is constantly losing
his girlfriend to Isaac any time he
comes on screen so Ellie liked Isaac
enough to date him but not enough to
stay with him but she also likes Norton
enough to date him but not enough to
stay loyal to him wonderful if this
sounds annoying don't worry we got 12
more chapters to go before this gets
resolved I understand why she left Isaac
and it makes sense but this character
drama being at the front of the story
and even taking priority during very
important narrative moments really drags
down the entire production Ellie left
Isaac because he couldn't confront his
past and talk about it he just held it
in and let it sit with him Ellie was
sick of having to deal with it so she
left she also wanted to destroy the
markers after having learned about them
on Titan station but Isaac wanted
nothing to do with the markers because
of all he's been through the reason and
even the concept itself is fine but like
I said it can really drag down the story
of times especially when some of the
characters entire personalities are
centered around this all of the
characters you meet are completely one
note buckle and Santos talk a couple
times a chapter and spoiler alert
they'll be dead soon anyway so don't get
too attached to them Norton is just
Isaac's competition for Ellie and Ellie
is just a love interest her character
has been completely shrunk to just being
an object for which the two Macho Man
bicker over oh and she also got her eye
back she bought a fake one in between
games figured I should mention that all
the characters just serve whatever
purpose they were meant to Ellie all the
way up to the end is just the love
interest every line of dialogue from
Norton is either about going home or
yelling and Isaac because he's Ellie's
ex-boyfriend Lauren never realizes that
he needs to set aside his differences
and deal with it after they finish the
mission because he goes out of his way
to sabotage Isaac by locking him in an
elevator so he can't get to Ellie tells
Ellie that Isaac is dead and that she
needs to move on when they crash land on
tal volantis make snark comments at the
two whenever Isaac and Ellie even show a
speck of a friendly relationship and
even betrays Isaac by working with danik
also that Isaac can die and that they
can go home even in his dying breath the
last words this man says is she doesn't
love you Isaac puts a bullet in his head
for this and thank God good riddance
Captain Cook may your legacy live on as
the one who couldn't win over his own
girlfriend what a waste of time
once Isaac meets with Ellie she says
that he needs to check the Admiral's
quarters because she wrote marker script
all over the walls and she believes that
the Admiral was trying to say something
on the way there we encounter more
Necromorphs but they look different this
time these Necromorphs are mummified
this is rather interesting as it shows
us another side of the Necromorph
biology if we remember from Dead Space 2
when the age of 7 marker was destroyed
the Necromorphs basically melted into
some soupy DNA but in here they aren't
so it's possible that if the Necromorphs
run out of people to kill but don't have
enough for a convergence event they lie
in hiding until something comes by once
making it inside Isaac finds the writing
and it says something about turning it
off in reference to some kind of machine
this machine is on the planet right near
the ship called Tau volantis before we
actually started playing instead of the
cutscene with Isaac it's actually a
prologue with some unimportant Soldier
he is a part of the Sovereign colonies
the predecessors of earthgov they came
here to investigate the marker signals
because they believe the markers could
be used to help them in one of their
Wars however the prologue ends on an
Abrupt note is both our character and
major mahad die before it fades to Black
Tim Kaufman the soldier we play as in
the intro was tasked by a Dr Earl
Serrano to get him the Codex this is the
same device major bahad takes from Tim
and wipes the data from Isaac and
Company were run into all of this later
but for now Isaac believes that turning
the machine off is the key to stopping
the markers the crew also believed that
tau volantis is the marker Homeworld if
you take into account the whole trilogy
and its progression this is a turn that
the story was inevitably going to take
we went from the early beginnings of
just discovering the Necromorph threat
to learning about the markers to then go
into the source it's a great transition
from one game to the next and also a
wonderful story beat it's what initially
got me interested in the story in the
first place it's just a shame that
before it circles back to this we have
to hear dozens of times from Norton that
Ellie is his and no one else's and have
to go around doing busy work just to get
to the planet besides the co-op missions
Dead Space 3 also has optional missions
they are interesting at first but don't
provide much of any information it's
either vague details about future
information you wouldn't be able to
connect to before the reveal or just
things you already know it was an
interesting way to break up some of the
pace but it also made the game a lot
longer than it needed to after about
three hours of busy work just trying to
get the ship running as you can crew
make The Descent down to Tau volantis
but due to the speed and the debris the
team ends up crash landing on the planet
Instead This is where a new gameplay
system gets introduced and it's centered
around Isaac's body temperature
tavalantis is a very cold Planet so
hypothermia May settle in if the crew
isn't careful so you have to move from
shelter to shelter without dying while
also fighting off waves of Necromorphs
it doesn't stay for the remainder of the
game but I did like it I think the
reason why was because it replaced those
spacewalks the previous games had they
weren't difficult but knowing that your
air could run out if you took too long
was a nice touch Dead Space 3 pretty
much removed that by making the air
capacity way more than the player will
ever need so these encounters saw to
replace them it's on tavolantus where
it's made clear that while some of the
old game systems have been changed or
lost to the wind its visuals haven't
tavolantus is a gorgeous icy Vista with
rundown buildings and skeletons of
creatures that are incomprehensible the
team's investigation leads them to the
carcass of what is called the Nexus in
terms of its role the Nexus pretty much
functions similarly to the hive mind of
Dead Space 1 a larger life form that
commands these smaller foot soldiers but
Communications can go both both ways so
instead of following the trail from the
Nexus to the Necromorphs if we instead
go backwards it may be possible to find
the thing giving it orders which they
assume to be the machine this requires
us to touch some of its nerve endings
with a pro gun while inside the dead
Beast Santos discovers that the signal
is underground but there's an entrance
further up the mountain so we'll have to
climb all the way up after this danik
and his Army start attacking Isaac gets
captured narna gets killed in a giant
Necromorph attacks this is actually
another Nexus that was at another base
but judging for the wreck it broke out
the fight's pretty cool though and
definitely delivers a high amount of
intensity throughout the fight this part
is a lot of what I was talking about
before in regards to this game's awful
middle Dead Space goes hours without
anything new it's either we learn
nothing or it's just one step of the
plan like with the Nexus we learned what
the Nexus is it's a Necromorph but we
don't know where this machine is we have
to go to the mountain to find it and
even then we still need to figure out
how to get inside the mountain the first
real chunk of information is related to
this being called Rosetta it's around
here where we finally get to understand
a bit more about what happened to
talvalantis from leaving the moon to
getting here it's about eight hours of
content and in that time we learned that
there's a machine and a large Necromorph
on the planet eight hours was slightly
longer than my playthrough of dead space
1. that's a whole game's worth of
nothing thankfully danik is interesting
enough to Warrant my attention his goals
are quite simple as it follows the same
unitologist's goal of starting
convergence but his line delivery and
voice acting is a treat to listen to
mostly because he's the same voice actor
behind Logan from Dragon Age a very
difficult thing you know undoing the
damage man has done everything we touch
we contaminate we corrupt
the markers had a plan for us but we
took what should have been a magnificent
gift and perverted it Jesus Bears the
[ __ ] it's also around this time that
Carver started to interest me not like I
had a choice though because he was shown
about a grand total of five times in the
game so far but he starts to play into
that [ __ ] tough guy role of his that
his character is based around and it was
incredible he and Isaac will eventually
get into one of their main arguments
over Santos's fate because Carver is
more than willing to cut the elevator
cable and does which Doom Santos but
saves the rest of them Isaac is furious
over this because he figured he could
save her but Carver and likely the
player knew differently this also
reinforces my thoughts on the character
so far as buckle dies around the time
they crash land and now Norton and
Santos are dead and the only one with
any amount of personality is Norton but
his whole character is based on being
the antagonistic Force to Isaac in their
love triangle taking them out changes
nothing in fact you could see it as you
play as each one of them becomes a
distant memory as the only ones actually
making any real ground in this game is
Ellie and Isaac while assembling Rosetta
Isaac will find some audio logs from an
Earl Serrano and right after after
assembling her do we finally get the
full story Rosetta is not a human nor is
she an ecromorph millions of years ago
will hold different race of beings lived
on the planet and use the markers the
same way humanity is using them now and
just like Humanity they too were overrun
by the infection but they came up with a
Fail-Safe they built a device that we've
been calling the machine so far to stop
the convergence because after that is
the final stage of the Necromorph life
cycle the brother Moon so in order of
events a black marker is sent down to a
habitable planet at some specific time
then it lays dormant until someone
discovers it once the species finds the
marker they're inevitably going to use
it thanks to its unlimited energy it's
hypothesized that this is intentional
because the marker's design and benefits
compel others to make more like we saw
with all the other markers thus far then
the process of the outbreak begins which
leads to a convergence event all the
copies then activate and further spread
the infection and all of its life forms
into a brother Moon the assumed to be
final step in the life cycle it's
entirely possible that there is
something even higher than this but we
never see that in the series so to our
knowledge the Brethren moons are the
final step according to Dr Serrano the
and creatures that used to live here
have gills and collapsed fins which
leads him to believe that's how volantis
used to be a planet filled with vast
oceans this ice age that occurred was
because of the machine as it was able to
flash freeze the entire planet stopping
the brother Moon from being complete and
leaving it in its unfinished State the
machine was activated via the Codex
which has now just been restored just in
time for danik to come in and take it
this is where the next Revelation is
revealed and it's that Isaac and Company
have actually been helping danek the
whole time the message turn off the
machine was not to stop the markers
turning off the machine thaws the planet
and resumes the convergence the Admiral
was being manipulated by the moon
because even in its half finished State
it's still able to control the marker
and was compelling people to stop the
machine and let it form and thanks to
Isaac danek now has the key to start the
convergence if we remember from earlier
the reason the Sovereign colonies were
here was to investigate the marker
signal and hopefully use it in a war
during this time though they discovered
what Isaac just discovered and realized
the real truth but the Necromorph that
was already upon them so they issued an
order to all the staff which was to turn
off all the equipment burn the date data
and self-terminate anyone who didn't
follow the last step would have had
someone do it to them by force it was
all in an effort to keep this hidden and
prevent the convergence from happening
that's why major mahad wanted the Codex
destroyed but Dr Serrano had another
plan he discovered that the flash freeze
on tavolantus wasn't the full plan the
original plan was to also crash the moon
into the planet killing it in the
process but for some reason it never did
so the Codex can either stop the machine
or fully activated depending on its
configuration danik of course wants to
make sure the machine stops Isaac would
want the opposite for the second time
now Isaac manages to escape a hostage
situation but Ellie had to be left
behind because the gas was funneling in
too fast and Ellie was killed yet not
really they couldn't kill off Isaac in
Dead Space 2 so they sure as hell are
not going to kill her off either to get
back to the more important info though
the reveal of the Brethren moons are
great and it's the main reason why this
game's DLC is so impressive dead space
from its opening moments has been about
Cosmic incomprehensible horror the
Necromorphs are this creation of
repurposed flesh that is so powerful
that no one has been able to stop them
at least without suffering some massive
casualty these along the way the
Brethren moons are like Eldritch Horrors
from Lovecraft in fact their motivations
are the same in the sense that they are
completely unknown we never learn why
the Brethren moons do what they do and
while that was likely due to the game
being canceled after this entry I'm fine
with this having the Brethren moons be
these all-consuming powerful beings that
just eliminate things for no reason is
terrifying it is exactly what dead space
is all about I also like this because it
inadvertently is an answer to the Fermi
Paradox I talked about this same idea
when discussing the Reapers in Mass
Effect 1 and it's pretty much the same
to give you a brief understanding of the
concept many people have wondered why we
haven't seen alien life yet some
attribute this to a great filter that
eliminates all species past a certain
point in the case of Dead Space 3 the
Brethren moons are that filter Humanity
within Dead Space hasn't seen any alien
species because the Brethren moons have
literally eaten all of them on the way
to Earth and just like the Reapers no
one knows how long they've been alive
the alien life on tauvalantis existed a
couple million years ago but that
doesn't mean that these aliens were the
first Target it seems like each species
creates one Moon and towards the end the
game we'll see about seven of them so
that would make Humanity the eighth but
nothing says that it's just seven we can
see maybe there's dozens of moons that
exist we never learn anything about the
moons and keeping their motivations
hidden makes them appear more Sinister
for the first time all game I felt
genuine fear and that's why I said Dead
Space 3's ending made at least some of
my time worth it the Brethren moons are
great aliens that escalate the game's
action while also keeping its horror
grounded their motivations may never be
learned but for a talking sentient Moon
I think that fits to get to the machine
Isaac will need to climb down the inside
of the mountain and while it's a long
climb the game doesn't want you to feel
too bored so it introduces its final
Necromorph it's a Necromorph that takes
the shape of the alien that we just put
together a few moments ago even though
it's just a standard looking alien at
least to their species since they
overpower humans and mass and strength
they feel like slightly weaker versions
of the brutes it's also a completely
original design that fits well within
the story Isaac and Carver then make it
to the bottom and they finally get to
see the machine this is also where the
two have a heart to heart and that's
what's so bizarre about it we have
barely mentioned Carver so far in this
video because we haven't learned much
about him and when you play solo that's
exactly how you're going to feel he
talks about alienating his son and
Wrecking his family like the player
knows this information and he also asks
Isaac if getting him this far was close
for it to count and that's all because
of his backstory Carver worked as a
guard at a marker site and one day he
got into an argument with his wife that
ended with her saying that she'd be
better off raising their son alone
shortly after this a missile was
launched and hit the building which
destroyed the Dome around the marker
protecting those around her from the
dementia and hallucinations two of its
victims were Carver's wife and son but
before she died she was able to leave
some info for Carver about the markers
and her research so he decided to do
what's right and make sure her mission
is complete that's why he asks of making
it this far counts because he wants to
make sure he didn't let his wife down
this mission of his is also how he
learned about Norton and Ellie so he's
already aware who these characters are
before the game starts and yet none of
this not his relationships nor his
backstory are ever going to be revealed
in Solo it sucks because I actually
started to like Carver as I continued
and I'm assuming I would have liked him
a lot earlier had I actually got to see
him more to get to the machine Isaac is
going to have have to go through a lot
of puzzles and combat Encounters in
order to reach the top while going
through the research facility you can
listen to some of Dr Serrano's work
which will help detail a lot of these
solutions to the puzzles like how all
the doors are voice activated but only
in the alien language but thanks to the
aliens themselves Ronald was actually
able to translate some of their language
he also hypothesized that the research
he uncovered from the aliens was
intentional and he assumes that the
alien species planned on newer species
coming to their Planet so they wanted to
make sure they could help them Isaac
then makes it to the top with danakir
taking Ellie as a hostage in the most
bizarre twist I have ever seen Isaac and
Carver actually switched roles as Isaac
is more than willing to let Ellie die if
it means the Earth is saved and Carver
wants to make sure Ellie is alive so he
tosses the Codex to danik who
deactivates the machine and Dooms the
world Isaac and Carver say their
goodbyes to Ellie as the two make their
way to the moon's core in an attempt to
stop it it's a cool set piece and a cool
fight even if it is a bit cheesy that we
hurl literal markers into the moon's
eyes but overall not a bad fight and not
a bad way to end the game either the two
then make it to the Codex come to terms
of what they're about to do activate
said codex which completes the actual
plan of the machine dragging the moon
down to the planet killing it alongside
with Isaac and Carver as they float down
to the surface Ellie is alive though
because she managed to find a shuttle
out of there she said that both of them
died but Earth gets to live another day
and that's why Ellie was told to leave
so she and the rest of the world can
live on it's a beautiful ending and one
that manages to wrap up just about
everything but it's all ruined at the
end of the credits when Isaac can be
heard calling Ellie's name they just
cannot kill this man off on the plus
side though him not dying was actually
the much better choice for only about an
hour of your time in the low low price
of 9.99 you can finish the story of Dead
Space 3 with its DLC awakened this
starts with Isaac waking up in his
apartment before being yelled at by
Carver the two eventually snap out of it
and realize that they are indeed alive
firstly if you were planning on Reviving
The guy don't spoil it at the end of the
credits let the DLC speak for itself
secondly it's almost funny how this
scene can be transferred over to the
writing room imagine these two aren't
Carver and Isaac but two writers on the
writing team that made this game
that doesn't make any sense
Isaac you activated the Codex the Moon
fell we fell
what about the alien machine
it froze the planet it pulled a moon out
of the sky
we don't know what that technology can
do
so that's it we were saved by [ __ ]
aliens
I quit trying to make sense of it all
back on the ishimura
it's just so funny to me because I can
imagine the writing team trying to think
about how these two survived and then
after thinking about it long enough they
just said [ __ ] it aliens this will never
get explained or talked about again I
mean Isaac does go into a small
monologue about how this might be with
the Necromorph C before getting slapped
upside the head by Carver but the two
don't question it and it's never
explained so it's just better if we move
past it despite the moon markers and
Necromorphs being dead the two still end
up receiving hallucinations this time a
lot more Vivid than before similar to
Nicole in Dead Space 2 Enemies are
appearing and then disappearing but a
few scenes will confirm that the
Necromorphs are anything but dead Isaac
will then get sent into a dream realm
that shows the moons in the distance
near Earth they also call off to Isaac
telling him to take the moons to Earth
and make them whole as Isaac continues
he'll notice strange markings and people
seeking refuge in some of the buildings
Apparently one of the members from
unitology here on talvalantis heard a
voice that spoke to him likely
referencing the moon so he believes it
to be their God that they have been
praying to which has led him in the
group to go even more call like in their
approach to appease them they literally
cut off their hands and replaced them
with metal claws while also putting
mechanical Parts on their back so that
they look like Necromorphs these guys
are delusional even more delusional than
unitology itself which is quite hard to
do the DLC is quite short but is where a
lot of Carver's personality starts to
shine because he's actually present in
this DLC he still doesn't show up in the
two split off constantly but they at
least talk with one another a lot more
than in the main game when Isaac and
Carver actually find a ship off tow
volantis they realize it has no shock
drive so they'll have to go back to the
Terra Nova the ship we found Eliana
originally and find a shock Drive core
in order to get them back home this
actually turns into an interesting
dilemma Isaac says that he can't go back
to Earth because the moons want to
follow him there Carver disagrees and
the tugany to a shootout I'm fairly
certain in Co-op the two of you actually
have to fight each other which if true
is amazing and is exactly what I was
hoping would happen the two clearly
can't die or else the story wouldn't
exist but the idea of Co-op players
fighting each other to the death is
always a great idea and is one of the
reasons I'm like Splinter Cell
convictions Co-op so much you spend
countless hours fighting beside that
person only to have to kill them by the
end Dead Space never goes as far as
killing someone I mean they could barely
kill off their own main cast but still I
enjoyed it nonetheless in Solo after
this fight they realized that they've
been duped the moons already knew where
Earth was they were just screwing at
them to buy some time the two however
managed to make it out pretty quickly
and head back to Earth
United mining traffic flow do you copy
[Music]
foreign
the moons have arrived the Earth is
doomed and the Necromorphs have won
I feel like if it was any other way I
would actually be more upset at that
outcome the moons are so powerful that
defeating them would never be possible
and having the game end as abruptly as
that fits in line with the rest of the
narrative Bad Endings are never fun to
see it's not good to know that the three
games worth of hard work that you and
Isaac have done together is for nothing
and that's just how the Necromorphs roll
they're here to kill and will do so at
the most inopportune of times regardless
the DLC was fantastic in fact from the
assembling of Rosetta to this cutscene
the game was incredible it was just
bogged down by so many poor choices and
priorities that it keeps it from being
amazing I managed to escalate the threat
that was established all those years ago
and even though mechanically it doesn't
feel like it narratively the looming
threat of the Necromorphs and the end of
all life is still very much present but
this game also makes characters that are
extremely forgettable and shoehorns in a
dramatic love story that goes on for
about 6 hours which is 6 hours too many
but no matter what you might say about
Dead Space 3 you can't ignore that at
the very least the story ends on a high
note with all of its narrative threads
that were still dangling severed by the
announcement of Humanity's imminent
attention
Dead Space is easily one of the best
probably the best survival horror game
I've ever played and its story was
exceptional there was a few hiccups
along the way mostly because of one game
but even still the progression of all
three main games flowing in a way that's
natural and intimidating Dead Space is a
game with an extensive amount of lore
that uses what makes sci-fi horror so
great and runs with it but it also
manages to not only tie all that into a
cohesive story but also be able to take
the horrors that those words they write
would impose and then transfer that into
the gameplay you feel scared while
playing the early games like you're
right there with Isaac going through all
the fleshy corridors and dimly lit rooms
Dead Space 1 deserved all the praise it
got it's a perfect survival horror game
that introduces the threat of the series
in such a fascinating way Dead Space 2
further expands on this idea by making
Isaac's role in the story as the marker
killer a bit more important while also
fleshing out a lot of the content that
was barely mentioned in the first game
like the markers and unitology Dead
Space 3 immediately Falls flat on its
face before picking itself up by its
bootstraps and somehow manages to not
only introduce new lore but also expand
on older lore in a way that makes
narrative sense all the way to the end
dead space in many ways is an impressive
piece of art from its actual art design
to its tones and themes and it's a game
I don't think I will ever forget playing
thanks for watching
if you enjoyed this video then leave a
like I have many more long videos like
this on other games you can check out if
you want to but also some short length
ones on single games as well if you're
new here then be sure to subscribe for
more content like this and as always
thank you to my returning viewers for
coming back to another video take care
everyone
goodbye